That would be a little hard to say.
But when I was eight years old,
my grandfather died and I knew that he
had written poetry because I used to see
him writing poetry in his box and I was
very close to him.
And uh,
after he died,
I went down to the basement of my family
house where my family kept books,
anthologies and things.
And there was an anthology without any
names attached to an,
I read a poem called spellbound.
And I somehow attached it to my
grandfather's death.
And I,
I thought my grandfather had written it.
In fact,
I was sure he had written it.
And it was a great constellation to me
and something planted in my mind that
you could write poetry,
that you could read poetry.
The portrait could somehow console you.
I didn't sit down then and start writing
poems,
but it was in the back of my mind.
Now when I was in high school,
I was leafing through an anthology that
our teachers had given us.
And I found it a poem.
I go,
that's so strange.
This,
this poem looks so much like my
grandfather's poem that I looked for
another one GRANDPA's poem.
It turns out it had been written by
Emily Bronte and it wasn't my
grandfather's poem at wall,
although my response to it I think was
pretty much the same.
I just had the author wrong.
Um,
but that was the beginning though.
I didn't start writing until I was in
high school and when I was in high
school,
I really began to,
I really began to write poetry with
great energy and enthusiasm.
I was in high school.
I used to show them to my sister and I
thought everything I wrote was so great.
And my poor sister,
who's a year younger than I am,
couldn't understand them at a wall,
but she was enthusiastic about my
writing them.
When I was a freshman in college,
I went to Grinnell College in Iowa.
I brought my poems to my freshman
humanities teacher whose name was Carol
Parson,
a wonderful teacher.
And Carol did a really great thing for
me.
She's,
she taught me more than anyone.
She somehow read my poems and came back
to me and convinced me that I could be a
poet,
that I had the passion and the
enthusiasm and the creativity to become
a poet.
But that what I was writing was not
poetry because I was just expressing my
feelings and I wasn't trying to make
anything.
The oldest word for,
for poetry and Greek is pollicis,
which means making a poet as a maker and
a poem as a made thing.
And Carol Somehow convinced me that I
could become a poet,
but that I was not writing poetry.
And then I would have to try and make
something,
um,
to write poetry and that I started then
to try and shape something rather than
just express it.
And when I started to shape something
and to imitate other poems that were
written by other people,
when I tried to integrate reading and my
writing,
I was on my payoff.
I guess that would have been 1968 I was
a freshman in college and I,
I wasn't writing good poems,
but I was at least trying to write
poems.
Then
there has been no poet,
no great poet in the history of poetry
who hasn't also been a great reader of
poetry.
This is sometimes distressing to my
students when I tell them this.
Now I do say it's possible.
You might be the first,
I'm not saying it's impossible,
but the odds are very much against you.
All great poets have been great readers.
And the way to learn your craft in
poetry is by reading other poetry and by
letting it guide you a great model for
this is the way that Dante calls on
Virgil at the beginning of the inferior.
No,
um,
the divine comedy to help guide them
through the underworld and in a way
that's also a recognition that Dante
needs virgil and that the infare inferno
needs the Aeneid and that the epic needs
a model and that for Dante to write this
great poem,
he needs someone to come before him and
he turns to Virgil's taxed,
especially books six where in the US
goes down into the underworld.
And for me that's a model of the poets
relationship to a pre to previous
poetry,
to another poetry as a,
as calling out for guidance.
There are many poets that I use as my
models.
Um,
in my first book of poems,
um,
I had several for the sleepwalkers,
I had several poems that were apprentice
poems like this in which I take a walk
with a,
with a poet who's no longer alive.
One of them as I walk with Federico
Garcia Lorca around the upper west side
in Manhattan because that was a
neighborhood he lived in.
And I imagine walking around Paris with
Cesar via whole Great Peruvian poet who
lived in Paris.
And,
uh,
I kind of,
I create the walk as a kind of drama of
my apprenticeship.
Now,
it is true that I think one of the
things that distinguished my work from
the beginning when I was in college was
my turning towards poetry from other
countries that I didn't ever consider
poetry.
The province exclusively of English and
American literature.
And I discovered a great amount in
reading,
Polish poetry and other eastern European
poetry and reading Russian poetry and
reading Latin American and Spanish
poetry.
And I've always found models in those
other poetry's of poets who could help
me on my payoff.
I think it shapes it in very deep ways
that you don't entirely understand.
Um,
Rainer Maria Rocha said there are two
sources for poetry.
One is dreams and the other is
childhood.
And I think childhood is an
inexhaustible source of your becoming
who you will be and certain deep
feelings are set inside of you a certain
construct of emotions that really define
who you are and who you will become.
And I feel very much that my childhood
is very alive inside of me,
very close to me,
very much part of me.
And I'm at an a sometimes painful,
sometimes joyous in exhaustible resource
for poetry and a lot of portraits.
Putting yourself back into the state of
wonder that you have before things when
you're a child,
it's not only a joyous wonder,
it's sometimes a grief stricken wonder.
Um,
I have,
uh,
the idea that lyric poetry is a poetry
that's driven by a sense of the presence
of death.
That there's something unbearable about
the fact that we're going to die and
that we can't stand it.
And I think you find that out in
childhood and you don't really,
at least I found that out in childhood
and I found that hard to get over.
And now I'm 60 years old and I still
find it hard to get over.
And I think it's one of the things that
drive lyric poetry,
our sense of mortality,
our sense that things are transient,
that everything is passing.
And then if you want to save something
from the endless flux of experience,
um,
and the world's movement,
you have to set down a steak and try and
make something that will last.